it's always young people that have the
that that their frontal well
a they they they they have all of this
energy
all of this passion and they want to
change the world right i mean you you
talk about young people
and always talking about they they want
cultural change they want a revolution
and they want to be part of something
bigger than themselves
a lot of a lot of the the older folks
i'm 50 now
uh we we have gray hair which is a sign
of wisdom we've been around a while to
see
that all this history stuff is actually
important
and so uh when you're young you need a
vision
and and so i think that if we give the
as older wiser people who understand
that ideas have consequences
that history can teach us uh about where
we're headed in the future
that if they get on board with with that
and they're inspired
if if uh if if they catch the vision
that's rooted in the right stuff i think
that
that not only i don't think that they
who are going to make the difference
i'm banking on the power of god
working in their hearts and through
their minds uh to make better decisions
than we've made in this generation
that's where my hope is
so as a guy that grew up as a as a kid
and as an atheist i suppose on
television then you have your kind of
awakening does it surprise you that
that hollywood is kind of where it's at
at the moment which i'm sure most of my
viewers will agree is not a great place
does it surprise me well you know
uh i i guess i don't know whether it
surprises me or not
um one of the things that i that i find
interesting is that when people
uh are afraid of public shame or
humiliation or condemnation uh we don't
like that right and so we tend to like
hide and we we don't let people see who
we are or really what we believe and i
i think unfortunately people within the
family of faith
have uh have felt that way and sort of
kept that stuff under wraps
even though um the world is increasingly
religious
uh i i believe that we were actually
designed to know and to love
uh god and and so we wind up worshiping
something if it's not god
whether it's yourself or it's the
government or it's a group of people you
think are smarter
but ultimately uh fr from that that that
source will come
our laws and it will dictate our
morality and all of that kind of thing
i hope that people of faith will begin
to
not divorce that faith from the arts and
entertainment
i hope that they'll take their faith in
their values and let it uh permeate the
things that will then shape
the culture and i think when we we see
more and more faith-based movies doing
better and better at the box office
you look at the chosen and you see how
well that's doing you look at the
quality of that you look at the passion
of
christ years ago and and even the movie
that i just finished uh
i think that people are are beginning to
say like wait a minute there's not only
a market for this
but this is actually communicating good
messages that most of us i believe in
america
understand we're getting away from and
we want to get back to those things
so i'm hoping for a revival uh not just
you know in in the heart of people of
faith but in hollywood
and in government and in the marketplace
and everywhere else
are you hopeful just because of how
crazy the last year and a half was
i've sort of come around to that that i
think so many people
you know yeah people are depressed
they're angry they're confused all that
stuff but
it caused them to look at their live
their lives more seriously
so i'm hopeful for that yeah i think
you're right and i think that
dave at the end of the day um you know
if you and i jump off a building
um we we don't break the law of gravity
the law of gravity breaks us
there are things that are built into the
world that are non-negotiables and i
think that false systems will always end
up failing they may
flourish for a while but it's kind of
like kind of like that big tree that you
see in the background
sometimes you know these these oak trees
get so big and top heavy with all their
big
uh impressive branches but if the root
system underneath
is not as developed if it's not down
deep
all it takes is a strong wind and the
thing topples itself
because it's way too top heavy and i
think our culture
is getting that way eventually it will
teeter and topple over because
our foundational roots of faith and
morality and virtue that our founders
said were absolutely essential for a
free society
have begun to rot and we've neglected
them so if we see rotten fruit
culturally
i think that the real answer is a
systemic answer
and we need to go down and we need to
begin to nourish the roots again
so you're sort of answering my next
question but how does the faith
that was pretty good what you did there
how does the faith part get you to that
flag
behind you and sort of shape you know
what you believe politically
yeah well i've never i'm really not a
political guy i'm
a family guy i would say i'm a faith guy
um
but i have kids in the world and i and i
i think to myself what's the place going
to be like in 20 years
that's a that's a terrifying question
when i think about where we're headed
right now politically economically
morally spiritually um that's why i'm
glad for your program i'm glad for uh
for for many others who are who are
communicating this message
and so what i did is as i said you know
what
um guys like george washington people
like uh uh
um abraham lincoln and and and the
pilgrims
even uh said that faith and morality are
absolute essential
for a free and just society and so i
began researching and educating myself
and i found that that the people who
built this country
did something that we're not doing
anymore and that is they're making these
these sacred promises with one another
to covenant together
um it's not just a legal contract that
we can show to a judge later when
somebody uh screws up and
and and uh you know uh breaks the
contract but it's it's this sense that
till death do us part are we are going
to
have each other's back and we're going
to do the right thing from the heart and
we're going to promise
with god as well that that if that if he
would protect us if he would guide us
that we we trust and believe that things
will go well
and our forefathers did that our four
mothers understood that it's what they
taught to their kids
and i believe that we need to go back to
that if we want to see america flourish
as a free and just society
even economically even educationally
all of these things i think are our
fruit
on the tree with the roots going down
into faith and and virtue
and that's what i'm trying to get people
to think about hoping that
we the people of america will come up
with a solution and not wait for our
hope
to fly in on air force one it ain't
coming
not not from any air force one but
particularly not from the guy on this
air force one
which uh which one of your sons did i
meet how old is he
so that's james and james is 18 and uh
he actually took his last
math final today and graduated high
school
wow very exciting day do i say
congratulations to you
i guess so you're the dad you got yes
thanks thank you
so tell jay as i said congratulations
but the reason i bring him up is because
i i met you at an event in florida a
bunch of his friends were around there
and you were saying oh dave you know
you've affected these kids and
and i love hearing that because it's
like oh that means that there are young
people who are
thinking about freedom thinking about
all the things that i talk about
are you are you hopeful like when you
talk to your kids of those ages who are
going to be the ones that
get us out of this mess like are you
hopeful that they can do it
yeah i am hopeful that they can do it
it's it's always young people that have
the
that that their frontal well a they they
they have all of this energy all of this
passion and they want to change the
world right
i mean you you talk about young people
and always talking about
they they want cultural change they want
a revolution and they want to be part of
something bigger than themselves
a lot of a lot of the uh the older folks
i'm 50 now
uh we we have gray hair which is a sign
of wisdom we've been around a while to
see
that all this history stuff is actually
important
and so uh when you're young um you need
a vision
and and so i think that if we give the
vision
as older wiser people who understand
that ideas have consequences
that history can teach us uh about where
we're headed in the future
that if they get on board with with that
and they're inspired
if if uh if if they catch the vision
that's rooted in the right stuff i think
that
that not only i don't think that they
who are going to make the difference
i'm banking on the power of god
working in their hearts and through
their minds
to make better decisions than we've made
in this generation
that's where my hope is what have you
done you and your wife i guess to to
make sure your kids are not
infected by so much of what's going on
out there with with critical race theory
identity politics just all the cultural
norms because
i get a ton of questions about that from
people that are of our old age 45 and 50
that are like what do i do about the
kids
well that's a great question and and i
don't um i i don't have the
i don't know that i have a
one-size-fits-all fix for that but
you know we homeschooled our kids for
many years and we didn't do that because
we were running away from something we
felt we could offer
our kids a superior educational path by
teaching them the values
and giving them the sources of
information and history about and
government
and literature and and faith that they
weren't going to get at a regular school
and then some of the years were actually
spent at private schools as well
but but this stuff is that you're
talking about is per it's pervasive
and so you know honestly i i i invite
friends
my kids friends and my friends to sit
around a campfire like this
and and to say hey what do you think of
that flag you know what what do you what
is important to you what are your kids
uh what are your friends dealing with
right now
you know in relationships uh politically
uh
you know what are the taboo things that
you can and cannot say and then we
discuss those things
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell